JP Morosi of the MLB Network he's
joining us right now John Merrow C Kirk
Morrison here filling in for rich how we
doing John Kirk I am outstanding my
friend it has been too long since our
days of talking on a weekly basis my
friend always loved catching up with you
on football baseball and all topics in
between yeah John will be part of a
mobile network 17 straight hours of live
open and day coverage beginning tomorrow
morning 9:00 a.m. Eastern visit MLB
network.com
for your local channel listings okay so
what are you doing for 17 hours John
where were you being are you in studio
are you on site where will you be it the
the local studio that I have here in
Michigan it might be Central every day
you can almost set your watch by it
every weekday around 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time
we've got a new new show tomorrow
launching Robert Flores joins the team
as a full time host of the show so it's
going to be a lot of fun I try to bring
a little bit of news a little bit of
perspective during that at 10:30 a.m.
segment every weekday so that'll be on
my docket from the from the hometown
studio there tomorrow okay good good
because now I need your your insider
information because you know I do a
spring training tour every year I go
down I bring the family we go down to
I'm a Cactus League guy I think I told
you that not a great fan Arizona guy so
I catch as many games as possible and so
I'm still trying to figure out the
biggest story line John going into this
MLB season is well I'm glad you asked
because to me it's the Yankees and you
teased it before the break we have not
had a repeat champion in Major League
Baseball since the Yankees in 2000 they
were of course won three straight 98 99
2000 back when Derek Jeter was a
shortstop and not a team owner which of
course now but I think to me it's it's
this rebooted reimagined Yankee team
bringing in Stanton people around that
team I saw the recent comments from John
sterling the radio broadcaster that he
is as excited about this team as he ever
has been for a Yankee season which I
think says a lot about all the stars
they've had in the past but you really
get the sense Kirk that here's a team
that was the dominant force in the game
for a period of time and now they're
back in
a big way not just getting to the ALCS
as they were last year but it's almost
as though the Yankees are back on the
map because anything short of a World
Series championship for them is going to
be a failure and speaking of teams that
are all in I love this as well on the
National League side curtain a storyline
I'm going to watch a lot during the
course of the year Clayton Kershaw is in
the final year before you can opt out of
his contract with the Dodgers Bryce
Harper's in the last year of his
contract with the Nationals there's no
way that both of them will be happy when
the season is over
because one of them at most one of them
can win the World Series and that is
where the bar is for both of them as
well so I love it you've got the Yankees
going all-in getting Stanton you've got
Kershaw and Harper desperate to win in
their final years with their franchises
potentially you've got a lot of
desperation for a lot of teams with a
lot of talent I love a lot of all in
teams right now Major League Baseball
MLB Network analysts John Morosi joiner
Rich Eisen show and John is I mean while
are we going to give Clayton Kershaw and
Bryce Harper the LeBron James treatment
this year of basically knowing they have
the opportunity to opt out and be free
agents or be a free agent altogether how
many times will they be asked the
question hey what are you gonna do about
next year because they're gonna hear it
all if the Dodgers go on a losing streak
or the Nationals aren't where they're
supposed to be how many times will we
hear these guys have to answer those
questions it's a great question Kirk and
I think it speaks to maybe just a little
bit of a different focus on on the big
one 62 of all the games and the way that
maybe those questions seem to be handled
down nowadays in baseball relative to
the NBA I think in in baseball Harper
came out at his very first press
conference of the season in spring
training and said basically if you ask
me about 2018 the interview is over
that's how we handled it so he did not
want to talk about it at all Kershaw has
always been somewhat guarded and
speaking about himself in his own plans
and so I don't expect we're to see a lot
of revelations coming out from Clayton
Kershaw during the coming months I think
it's interesting that in that in the NBA
and I love this by the way about the NBA
the players are are outspoken and are
very aware
their ability to basically control the
chess pieces of the entire landscape
with the league it's like am we all go
to this team we're going to be dominant
we're going to win and I love the fact
that it's very out there in the open and
then people talk about it and in
baseball it's a little more guarded
which I think both we understand certain
who's going to be a free agent it's not
as though that by not talking about it
from Harper standpoint that we are going
to talk about it any less because I
think we're still going to talk about as
much as we all were already wanted it's
just without his input I love the way
that LeBron and Chris Paul and Kevin
Durant that the big stars of the NBA
have been very outspoken and maybe
steering the conversation in that
direction and maybe we're gonna see a
time maybe in the next couple years
where baseball gets to that point as
well but it does well seem to be that
that the players are being quite so
candid as maybe we see in basketball
so no Miguel Cabrera and Bryce Harper
kind of power team at some point earlier
in the year I think Aaron judge in
spring training talking about Manny
Machado where that was found upon so I
think it's just a different a different
culture in terms of how much it's talked
about and I think that's that's the
unique part a great part about our
country that each sport has its own
lexicon own way of doing business and
for now I think baseball is more focused
on the the long march ahead of the the
six month regular season and of course
the one month to playoffs at John Merrow
see on Twitter you can follow John
Merrow see MLB Network endless there on
Twitter I was at a spring training I
told you a couple weeks ago and I was
trying to figure out where do you fall
on this show hey Otani right now he's
come over here and the velocity is not
what people thought it was going to be
John he only had maybe one or two hits
and all of spring training are the
Angels having buyer's remorse or what
should we expect or how are the Angels
going to handle this show hey itani this
season
first of all Cooke I would say the
angels are not having buyer's remorse in
large part because the investment was
not that big it was it was a relatively
small signing bonus because of the way
baseball's international rules work for
amateurs which Otani was until he signed
this contract so I think from a
standpoint
the outlay they've got to be comfortable
with it they sat down there was a really
in-depth recruitment process and I think
a lot of trust was developed between the
front office of the angels and his
representation at CAA so I think on that
end of things the angels are going to be
very reluctant to change and really
disrupt the the overall process that
they had put in place with proton II a
month ago just based on one month of
underperformance and candidly it has
been as you point out for hits all
singles command has been spotty on the
mound it was not the spring that they
wanted to see out of him no question
about that all that being said he's
going to start believe it's the fourth
game of the year on Sunday against the
A's and the angels hope somewhat of a
lesser pressurized atmosphere it's not
going to be the season opener not going
to be the home opener so just trying to
let them settle in but to your point
Kirk the performance has not been there
the ages I'm sure is still happy that
he's on their team but they may have to
get very creative I would say this on
Otani watch very carefully about a month
or six weeks in if he's not hitting what
do they do do they just say you know
what we need you on the mound more
because that's true they need it more as
the pitcher than a hitter do they scrap
the hitting Italians they listen we want
you to focus on this one really hard
thing which is pitching in the big
leagues as opposed to trying to do two
really hard things at the same time it's
a great question Kirk and it's a great
topic overall but I think they're gonna
be guarded in their optimism stay with
the plan but look for an audible
potentially being called about six weeks
into the season if things are not going
the right way a couple more for you here
John um you know I'm a Bay Area guy so
I'm actually ask you about first of all
the San Francisco Giants
obviously Madison Bumgarner getting
ready his last spring training start he
gets you know hit on the throwing hands
gonna be out the next two months and you
talked about teams going all-in
we know the Giants several Giants
they're going all-in as well what does
this do for the early part of the season
or this just does this derail the san
franpsycho Giants at all the injury to
Madison Bumgarner it's a fascinating
subject Kirk and of course
- the Samara injury as you point out not
just one picture at the - so starting I
love this by the way starting tomorrow
Dodgers Giants marquee rivalry goes back
to the early part late part of the 1800s
there in New York City
this ancient rivalry the matchup is
going to be not curse on Bumgarner
Kershaw and Lefty ty blach and you say
if you're a Dodger fan well we've got a
good chance to win this game
not necessarily ty blach in his career
against the Dodgers a 2 point 2 3 e ra
for some reason they just do not see him
very well he's actually the quality
pitcher that I think people are
overlooking here so I would say the
Dodgers and their fans do not count on
an easy win at opening days because the
Giants are throwing a guy in block who
they've really struggled with optimized
from a Dodgers offensive standpoint but
to your point they really went all in
trying to fortify this club after a
disappointing finish last year they were
last place in the NL really overall last
place in the whole league but they bring
in McCutchen they bring in Longoria and
Kirk I'm encouraged by this they had the
best team o-p-s of any team in the major
leagues this spring training now you
could say well what any numbers mean
right to me it says this lineup was not
as bad as it looks last year I'm not
saying they're the best team offensively
but they're certainly better than what
we saw in 2017 so I'm optimistic they're
gonna have to find a way though to hit
their way to some wins early on because
they'll have some untested younger arms
and rotation and Derek Holland coming in
as a minor-league free agent even we
part of that opening their rotation
there for the San Francisco Giants last
question for you John a stinky situation
here in Los Angeles last night the
sewage bad I guess a pipe burst
something like that with the Dodgers
last night the game was was canceled in
the fifth inning between the Dodgers and
angels will that affect anything for
opening day have you heard anything or
even a game ending the way that it did
last night
yeah regarding changing of plans for
opening day but certainly an alarming
circumstance we've seen this happen
before at the Coliseum yes
Dodger Stadium people often forget
third-oldest stay
'i'm in baseball the only two that are
older Fenway and Wrigley it looks
gorgeous but there are some older bones
there that maybe we have to take a look
at they're going forward
agent appreciate the time my pleasure my
friend love to catch them again roasted
okay yes sound good I'll pick your brain
before that was John Merrow CMO beat
Network analyst joint he's on Twitter at
John Merrow see the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience